the las vegas veterans day parade
returns tomorrow was canceled last year
because of the pandemic this was
actually video then from two years ago
tomorrow's parade starts at 10 a.m it's
going to be in downtown las vegas at
fourth and gas we should have some great
weather for it
it will feature a four plane flyover and
120 different groups including of course
vets bands and rot rotc units so
tomorrow is veterans day when our nation
comes together to honor the incredible
sacrifices made by the men and women in
our military those who have received a
purple heart were wounded while serving
our country kate houston live in studio
after attending a very special ceremony
for our local purple heart veterans
yes four purple heart veterans were
honored today and since their service
these vets have dedicated their time to
supporting the more than 200 thousand
veterans all across nevada they're
advocating to end homelessness and
provide more mental health resources
daniel peterson served nearly 25 years
as a helicopter pilot he did two tours
in vietnam granada and desert storm
where his helicopter was shot down twice
peterson himself has been shot seven
times he now runs the purple heart
chapter in henderson advocating for 130
local veterans peterson says a key issue
right now is suicide all of us
veterans who have served have ptsd
you know i go to group counseling
that's what keeps me going so
we fear for what's going to happen with
them you know they've got it they've got
to get out there and get help u.s
senator catherine cortez masto
congresswoman susie lee and henderson
mayor deborah march attended the
ceremony at bellavita to help shine a
light on the issues veterans are facing
today during that time peterson was
recognized by 15 major organizations
they say he is one of the most decorated
veterans in the country and a national
hero
all of the money raised today will go to
veterans organizations bellavita
restaurant is also collecting donations
online through their social media
accounts